welcome to Hannity now as you know every
night we begin this is a national
emergency that our country is going
through it continues we start every
night with facts without fear just the
facts and that means the good the bad
the ugly what should most concern you
and your family sadly at this time we
see the worse than some people but the
majority we see the best in we're going
to name names America needs to know but
we start tonight with an important
message from the president earlier today
take a look I want every American to be
prepared for the hard days that lie
ahead we're going to go through a very
tough two weeks and then hopefully as
the experts are predicting is I think a
lot of us are predicting after having
studied it's so hard you're gonna start
seeing some real light at the end of the
tunnel but this is going to be a very
painful very very painful two weeks now
the president's night we all need to
face the truth make no mistake the next
two weeks maybe longer will be rough
here is where we are up-to-the-minute
tonight in order to prepare FEMA has now
supplied 250 ambulances and 500 EMTs to
New York that is the point of interest
right now it could spread elsewhere the
Army Corps of Engineers they are
developing eight facilities to expand
hospital capacity in California
including hundreds of additional sites
across the US FEMA is soon delivering a
250 bed field hospital in the state of
Michigan and additional field hospitals
now being built in Louisiana up to 500
beds as of now and a 3,000 bed alternate
care site they're building that in New
Orleans also FEMA is now also providing
a hundred travel trailers to help with
housing needs and the administration
they are giving hospitals the
flexibility to use new facilities for
non infected people if that is in their
best interest they're on the ground they
need to make those decisions now so far
this country has completed 1.1 million
tests that's more than anywhere else in
the world by far but that is not all
today we got more facts without fear
from President Trump about America
supply for example we've heard so much
about ventilators let's take a look we
have
almost 10,000 ventilators that we have
ready to go we have to hold them back
because the surge is coming and it's
coming pretty strong and we want to be
able to immediately move it into place
without going and taking it
we sent a large number of ventilators to
Michigan we're sending them to Louisiana
we sent additional ventilators to New
York
additional ventilators to New Jersey now
keep in mind multiple major US companies
are now mass producing new ventilators
between Ford 3m General Motors over
10,000 additional ventilators will be
ready by mid April that's coming up 15
days with thousands to follow much of
50,000 thereafter and tonight there are
so many great businesses we do have to
stop these people have gone to bat for
we the American people they deserve our
praise tonight and more importantly we
owe a debt of gratitude to all the
Americans in every corner of this
country rising to the occasion
starting with O our military men and
women that are now helping amazing
Americans National Guard this is the
best of our country has to offer we can
see this in the roughest of times and
earlier today the president saluted the
brave doctors and scientists and nurses
and all the health care professionals
they all put their lives on the line
they do it around the clock around the
country tirelessly working for the
American people
in the frontlines to beat back this well
invisible enemy take a look I watched
the doctors and the nurses walking into
that hospital this morning
it's like military people going into
battle going into war the bravery is
incredible and I just have to take my
hat I would take my head if I were
wearing I had I'd rip that hat off so
fast and I would say you people are just
incredible they really are they're very
brave these medical workers they have a
tough road ahead all praise to them
tonight and by the way this brings us to
our facts without fear these are the
things that we've got to keep an eye on
as a country we all need to be concerned
about worried panic hysteria that's not
the
so we got to think strategically we got
to stand back make the best decisions we
could make based on new information
involving everyday hospitals around the
country they are now being stretched
dangerously thin protective medical
supplies we are getting reports are
running low in areas one big concern is
more people younger people are being
impacted remember every single expert
for pretty much five six weeks said and
reported just the very opposite only
older people with underlying conditions
or compromised immune systems
now if the patterns that we see and have
witnessed around the world hold in the
united states new corona cases will
sharply rise especially because we're
doing more testing than anybody else
remember there are people that are
asymptomatic some people will not even
know that they ever had this virus the
death toll will lag behind but as dr.
Fauci and others said today we will then
see a sharp increase before we see the
virus level off and ultimately what we
all want to decrease then I'll get back
to the lives we want to live the White
House now predicting it is possible
between 100,000 and 200,000 deaths in
the US but it could have been 2.2
million very interesting charts let us
hope for the best case scenario take a
look dr. battle should Americans be
prepared for the likelihood that there
will be a hundred thousand Americans who
die from this virus the answer is yes we
need as sobering a number as that is we
should be prepared for it is it going to
be that much I hope not and I think the
more we push on the mitigation the less
likelihood it would be that number but
as being realistic we need to prepare
ourselves that that is a possibility now
this is why the president extended the
social distancing plan until April 30th
our medical experts are saying that will
prevent people from contracting the
virus and exponentially that will
mathematically prevent people from
ultimately dying we want to save
American lives we believe in life we
protect the lives of people all across
this globe we got to protect Americans
all hands on deck now it is a concerning
number frankly downright scary and we
hope and prayed that we never get there
and that lives are saved
doctor foul she talked about it that
could all happen too and now because of
the president's decisive actions we have
time to potentially curb that number and
mitigate this disease travel ban that
brought us a ton of time the quarantine
also bought us time our current period
of social distancing is buying us more
time now the thing is no president has
done war acted more quickly the book on
pandemics has now been rewritten future
generations will learn from the lessons
of this pandemic never before have all
of these new things happen now hospitals
and doctors and American businesses they
have time to fight back as they have
been look at the announcement this week
Abbott Labs creating a five-minute test
that will be a game changer studies now
underway to determine the effects of new
treatments and a vaccine is already in
phase one trials it used to take years
to get the sequence of a virus American
ingenuity brilliant scientists medical
researchers and doctors incredible
people all of them and meanwhile also
American businesses have started
mass-producing personal protective
equipment wherever the need is that our
health care professionals that they
desperately need and we must provide for
them and n95 respirators mask gloves
shields protective suits are now being
made by companies all across America now
this great American ingenuity and hard
work is part of the facts that should
give you hope tonight and tonight we
have other good news to share
we'll start in California where after
two weeks of strict social distancing
policies doctors are now cautiously
optimistic that that curve is now
flattening out around the Bay Area and
according to political hospitals are
reporting fewer cases than they expected
to see that is good as we look at this
now the scary time that we're heading
into New York New Jersey Connecticut and
maybe some other hotspots around the
country last week Washington State they
saw a decrease in the pace of new cases
particularly around sea
adil a lot of good work by the governor
out there meanwhile in Italy Europe's
coronavirus epicenter all new cases have
finally of the virus begun a process we
hope of leveling off and we are now at a
two-week law and according to a brand
new study from a medical journal in the
United Kingdom the death rate they say
for koban 19:00 those cases could be as
low as low as 0.9 but what is certain is
the might the will the power the
ingenuity of you we the American people
soon this invisible enemy it will be
defeated but hang on tight the next few
weeks will definitely be rocky that's
especially true in the state of New York
where we are tonight which is now the
epicenter at this moment of the disease
and today the state released a statement
once again blaming the federal
government they released this statement
the states were not slow to respond the
federal government was absent okay
Andrew Cuomo you were missing in action
mayor de Blasio you were missing in
action really you have the highest per
capita taxes in the country New York
state and city and virtually zero
stockpile of equipment masks gloves
nothing the stockpile of ventilators
totally insufficient and the states had
fewer ventilators on hand than the
national average in fact former
lieutenant governor of New York betsy
mccoy points out the cuomo was warned of
the shortage of ventilators in 2015 they
only had 2000 the task force reckoned
that recommended they needed 18,000 so
instead of buying 16,000 more Cuomo did
nothing and now he's screaming at the
president who's building hospital after
hospital sending all the ventilators
that he puts in a warehouse now he's
lecturing the president well that's why
the federal government sent over 4,000
to you that you stuck in a warehouse
multiple emergency hospitals we now have
the USNS comforter right there in New
York Harbor and it gets even worse
Cuomo barring New York citizens this has
got to end
hospitalized if you're not hospitalized
the last place you want to be is in a
hospital right now if you can prevent it
but now the only place you can go in the
state of New York to get
hydroxychloroquine is that a pharmacy
and they're not allowed to give it to
you that's right Governor Cuomo rescind
that order and take responsibility why
didn't you buy those ventilators you
spent seven hundred fifty million
dollars on a failed solar panel project
in upstate New York
it went belly-up why don't you spend
money on gowns really you're gonna
attack the president the federal
government in the middle of an emergency
you also take responsibility for your
poor planning New York is the number-one
terror target in the entire world New
York should be prepared
the first Trade Center attacked 9/11 New
York highest concentration of 10 million
people smallest geographical location
and a pandemic New York City is ground
zero an international city